bro I'm drinking my cold brew mocha it's
a mellow it's a mocha they put a little
chocolate in there yeah it takes them 24
hours to make see that's a lot you know
me when it comes to artisanship if you
show me the difference between the grain
of wood on something if you say this is
good but this is really good like this
guy was shoving that difference been
Pavarotti and then Pavarotti the great
opera singer like he sings well he goes
yeah but you don't know listen to this
and he played me this other guy blind
guy who's now it was a guy who if you're
the real aficionado of opera and I
didn't know the difference but I was
like there is a difference though
there's a difference I'll buy into it
dude you know I like it's money I'll say
it's funny you say that yeah because I
gotta get rid of the monster truck right
cuz that truck will excuse me why anyone
let me buy that no idea how are we on
that one I don't know I don't need too
big it's too big kill a learn that you
have to learn the hard left to go yeah
you have to go big and then learn the
hard way everything the hard way cuz
you're the most stubborn person like
there's no way anybody's telling you
what to do until you go oh this isn't
I'm trying to back this Papa needs to
learn I got it I can't get this pump in
June yeah Tommy store went dude we love
you but you can't parking lot anymore
cuz your car takes up three spots and we
can't get it we can't get you out just
really can't go there so I ran over the
store now improv - we can't ballet it
takes up too much lap factor dude we
just me up I'm like all right here yeah
is there any way you can't just drive
the Ferrari because we bring the Raptor
it blocks everyone on it oh yeah well I
can't drive it anywhere because it's a
monster truck in LA Brendan yeah and
you're a [ __ ] so that's not gonna work
see I get rid of quotes why do you have
the two tires in the back oh yeah cuz
I'm gonna offroad because I'm an
off-road
I know ours like never right so that
thing you know that thing that the guy
was shocked it's like I don't know cars
and I know you're a nut nut for it so I
just I just want up the boat most BC
rapper yeah yeah right so I got beastie
Raptor the guy who had it before me goes
yes so the shots on this man you're
gonna you can go Baja if you want you
jump out rocks you know it yeah no doubt
probably the only thing this thing go
over is a speed bump on [ __ ] Laurel
Canyon yeah really a speed limit you're
supposed to get any goes ray oh yeah and
I see him go that's a shame
Wow look out whatever dude you
right that thing's not gonna fit in my
lifestyle Nell a so you get rid of it
so yesterday as I need a dad right yeah
Verizon how do you get rid of that you
sell that I think it's not like hotcakes
in real hiya the color the combo
everything that I paid for on that
thing's gonna be [ __ ] I got my guide
Greg right he's a monster
so we're have four bit done so I was
yesterday I went with Greg to go drive
other dad cars and this is to your point
where you're saying the difference
between things so he takes me and it's
called a GT it's a four-door GT Mercedes
uh you only have two doors or that four
doors now it's like Baltimore dad car
bring that up so there's a Mercedes GT
four-door but it's the GTS right
it's the GTS hatchback so it's a mantra
it's like I don't know 700 horsepower oh
Michael it's a monster AMG right that's
it that's exactly when I test drove the
GTS so I go what's the price they tell
me I go what's monthly bill cake right
off the law and I go well I don't need
the ass I don't need to ask and then the
guys Greg goes yeah maybe I'll feel the
difference I want people feel difference
well he starts going the engineering of
the ads the problem and that this stare
and they get to you and do that to you
cuz you go oh don't put me in that first
no don't put me in that first because
then the other thing drives like well he
goes okay I get out of it when I'm sad
ah how much does your payment probably
half like it's just not I'll be sad I'll
be think about that one the whole time
so ya reconsider everything ah it's true
man when you the quality that's why you
know you make funny with Ferraris or
Mike no that's I know what these these
now listen yeah we making the transition
out of those well no this is the same
thing you have can I be honest let me
just stop for a second they have small
fins on the back so are you are you who
is the guy who is it laughs are you
flash
but there's another there's a god bless
just [ __ ] who's the god the Greek god
with wings on his feet the keel Hermes
nice Hermes your are you husky Hermes on
the thicker means ethnic Hermes your
husky Hermes hurry clothing because
those things have those things they you
look like you're wearing mini Porsches
on oh I'll take that but listen this
dude this designer
his name's June Kutta Hoshi yup his name
is June takahashi
check it out jump he won against the
government in Japan right so he's one of
the these are undercover CLAB so June
Takahashi went against the oh it's in
China I'm sorry in China he pulled off
his shoe so he's one of the top
designers but because he went against
the government China
you can't sell his shoes that Takashi is
Japanese Japanese but but they pulled
like he went against the go no he did
okay the Hong Kong protests so they say
honk so they pulled all his collapse
well Papa got news from the underground
so he's a hard to get so he went and
bottom they won't sell shoes in Ghana
underscored lab now you can you can go
[ __ ] off with the shoes also because I
don't care but but what do you like
about them so much dude it's just just
because you look like - dude the effort
and the quality that went into these
shoes not quality same with your coffee
and everything yeah cuz if you compared
these as a regular pair of like Cortes
or something like that or running shoes
yeah dude what are we doing really like
driving that other car alright so are
you making me are you gonna wear the FS
can you please not do the S can you
please save the money it's half as much
well not exactly but it's a lot of
savings I mean are you gonna do you're
gonna be in traffic sir
you know this right I'm really not
there'll be but but but but you are but
I take a car I take Topanga and then
also but that's a dad car so I take to
pay a dad car that's 700 horsepower
please stop calling what's the biggest
dad car of all time but it's not a bad
car right it is though cuz I'm a dad but
I get to give me in the back it's not a
bad carcass the inside screaming it with
a helmet so it's not a bad car well no
he could be then no maybe a father no
see I have to no see I have to stop here
because the dad's car with dad car man
why don't you do this will you please
try will you please reven the in test
drive please test for Tesla I will pay
no no no I can't have [ __ ] 90 it
looks like [ __ ] it looks like [ __ ] it
does nothing it bring that Tesla I
guarantee
if you get in this GT four-door AMG GTS
and the engine size better [ __ ]
pickup now it's electric it doesn't do
anything for me dude that's my dad Lord
just tell SUV and then I'll typing gay
at the end
dude please though the thing you tell me
other things sexy look is that thing
sexy in any fashion
I love does that do anything anybody
doors dude you make fun of my shoes in
your sell me on this stage oh your shoes
with lean they go with your shoes you
know that thing's not sexy compared to
the one I was just looking at you know
it is the problem is you need you need
because that you know I love to drive
you started your Ferrari up yesterday
and you know that I'd I mean I jumped I
jumped I went well no I jumped I jumped
with fright oh and daddy's getting new
exhaust on that tomorrow oh come on
please daddy please don't soup up your
Ferrari please daddy
that's that Ferrari your guy told me
that he needs to have somebody come to
teach you how to drive it oh we've been
through that because it's so it's it's
such a monster and they don't make it
imagine yeah I know please don't soup it
oh please Donna was uh I was standing up
on the spot last night
it was awesome I did I did I made for
that if I did a story about street
fighting in French that's hilarious they
really liked that go anyway speak French
no well and you know the great thing
about stand-up on the spot as you come
up with bits like it gave me a really
good eye did you record it
I was Renaud I in my mind I know what to
do now but you know I'll do is I'll
record it but then in the back Jeremiah
go dude you should think about this this
and this
yeah yeah it was good who is you rogue
you and me Rogan us rock Jerry Seinfeld
yes well right Jeremiah who else I don't
know I don't even know the old a girl
from one of the girls Christina from the
podcast guys we [ __ ] I don't know I
don't know
interesting buddy has fun that was fine
oh you saw her it was fun though yeah
you you saw our buddy
Rockhold he's in town I saw Luke house
I'm doing buddy he's got some problems
with his job but he's gets broke but
he's okay he's broken before I don't
think he's ever broken before no no I
think he's working hard
yeah yeah well I think you know I think
he's a good place in tizzy I do I think
he's in a good place in terms of you
know he's he's got this he's got a lot
of options like we were talking about
yeah man it's not a sad story
yeah and he's done everything he had to
do in there in the UFC I told you Hall
of Famer there's nothing else for him to
do if you want to stick around fight at
205 you can do that and I think it'd be
his choice I have no idea but yeah main
thing is just to get some stuff you know
these days out here just chillin
recovering yeah you know what's
interesting is you you have been there
17 fights and 75 count my ultimate
fighter I'd be 20 then 24 24 to a lot of
fights a lot of fights to have I I
forgot I didn't know you were that
extensive but I guess you did fight for
eight years a while I mean that's a long
time so when you are intimately involved
in something you know you can see things
that other people don't just cuz you've
been there and you can see the
subtleties and the nuances and and the
mindset and I think you are how old were
you when you when you were contemplating
retirement I retired my last place to
I'm 13 yeah so that'd be that'd be what
six years ago and then but it happened
for that so you're talking about but
damn there's seven half years almost
eight years is when I start to thinking
about it then I did it legitimately six
years ago yeah I don't know you know I
don't want to speak for Luke I don't
like what's in his head but but I don't
have to I don't to a TV yeah I'm telling
you man yeah I'm telling you when I I
just know I debts is a one advantage I
have over all I'm not a journalist but
I'll you know when I do below the belt
the one advance have overall them if I'm
in it I've been in there I know exactly
what they're going huge experience yeah
so but in the actual field do you want
listen to a guy who also listen I'm
Scott Easwar do you want to talk about
the guy who was on the battlefield
who's on the battlefield and also the
guy who's six
seated and failed who's got knocked out
has knocked out has done all these
things I beat some of the best I lost
some of it I I would say that losses
also are it's more important in terms of
experience understand the huge brother
[ __ ] understand huge what really goes
on it's huge what sigh yeah so I can
comment when you destroy this set you're
like guy but when you bomb that you
really go back to the start work on the
things like well that didn't work there
that didn't work there so think I'm
fighting when you get knocked out like
right well this isn't working even
though some of it's working go back and
you just you really dial in on what you
need to do it's a really good speech by
our own Schwarzenegger he gave a
commencement speech I thought was really
really good there you know not a lot of
people are successful in that many
genres is mr. Arnold Schwarzenegger I
mean and and and you know what he said
um he said I don't like Plan B's when
you're going for something I know gotta
be all-in you better be on whatever
you're in you better be Yellin he said
because you're competing with people who
are all in and if you have a plan B if
you have an op option in anything in
life when you're trying you know and and
I think that's an important thing to
keep in mind for put especially with
fighting be my mother any doubt if
there's any doubt that's what I
consequences the consequences are listen
if you want be a singer and you'll have
a plan B you don't make it alright
you'll find something else in fighting
if you have if you have a plan B you're
gonna get really really injured so the
consequence are so dramatic like just
don't do it it's not on your body I've
always said your body will tell the
truth your body whether you say whatever
you want your brain can say whatever you
want it's like a little bit like like so
with my psoriasis that had to do with
emotional [ __ ] that I was not just okay
and once I took care of that hold it
what yeah he had your day so I saw my
mother once I dealt with with the issues
of my life that were not resolved and I
dealt with them honestly and have
confronted them what a surprise that my
psoriasis went away so a lot of times
you may say you're into something and
you're not but your body will tell the
story now it'll I think I'm fighting
when you were gonna fight Travis brown
and I saw your face and you were like I
just wasn't into it well you didn't even
have any energy in your body well guess
what can't fake it
you can't fake it because your body was
like hey we don't want to do this so
your body shutting down you're tired yes
it's all this cuz you know why you had a
[ __ ] plan B I had a plan B and C I
remember it because you were sitting
there and we were we were we would we
would always bond we'd all be sitting
around laughing and telling stories in a
bar and even if you weren't drinking
how's the best we would just be laughing
and talking and I remember you said we
go how good is this somebody says how
good is it's just a hang and talk like
this and you go so I want to do so I
want to do and I go and I went well
that's all I want to do I looked at you
and I went oh oh a big smile on your
face and I was like oh well I was
delighted because you know I was like
good but but at the same time that can't
be all you want to do Jorge Masvidal
that's not all he wants to do he wants
to put his fist through your face you
know it's a different thing but I think
that's really the honest horris never
say I don't like Plan B's be all-in when
you win you and my mother said to me
when I was an actor I never forgot this
she said she sat down and she said what
is your plan B do you think you should
go back to school and get your law
degree or get your MBA in case this
doesn't work out and I remember I looked
at her and I said I don't have a plan B
baby this is it if I don't make it you
come on Plan B baby no I see on the
other side no one it goes on I go I
don't have a plan B baby and she goes
see ya she goes what and I go shut up
and I go come here and I made out and
then I go yeah yeah Denny went you're
disgusting mama yeah
yeah see in Hollywood yet and and then
and I have I have a son who's also my
brother yeah but that's an important
thing I I see so many people and I know
you took the same thing on the road one
of my favorite things to do is when I
don't bring Derek in a song with me I
have other the local talent I talked
this one guy I could tell like he did
his first set and it was rough man and
come to the back you know I did yeah I
mean I'm around the [ __ ] Comedy Store
I see the best in the world
so the guy comes back and I go I in you
know Jays with me all the time in J you
know he sees everyone and James on rough
was definitely I went I bet you he
hasn't been doing stand-up comes the
back link oh hey brother I mean how many
times a monthly getting up around here
goes maybe once a month got a lot going
on away oh well what oh you're not doing
stand-up dude he's not coming
well no you know I can't comic dude I'm
around guys who I mean they're getting
up four or five times a night if you're
not driving deal hour and right like no
night beam that I guys you know Derek
and a son they drive to San Diego on a
Wednesday night to do six minutes I love
that then drive back to Burbank do a
spot and then the you know they get on
another show like you're not in the race
so the the Plan B or whatever you're
doing you're not all in your compared
gonna sound are all in that yeah that's
who you're competing with I don't give a
[ __ ] it's my same advice to when Mark
moon is s we talked those guys about
coming to practice all right well then
I'm in the race like if you have to tell
people come to practice or if you tell
comics and make sure they're getting
their sets and do you not what I'm in
the same boat that is so frustrating to
me I'm always like hold on it's not why
are you not eating and breathing this
that's why I think life is fair a lot of
times a lot of times it's not a lot of
times it is success like when you see
people are really successful not an
accident especially if it's prolonged
success not an accident take a look at
how they lived their life and then take
a look at how you live your life and
what will happen is I always say it's
about Hollywood I didn't make it as an
actor for a long time because I didn't
want to act so my body my body when I
went into our auditions for emoji yeah I
wasn't ready I didn't get ready for the
audition because I didn't want to be on
a set it's fair it is fair now so no
some real talent I know that guy want
anymore yeah I got way better that's the
well he might be just as talented buddy
works his ass off or not as talented but
he's prepared in your inner parrot he's
prepared I saw that I saw certain actors
that were really famous well I watched
Bradley Cooper that [ __ ] was
Bradley Cooper was gonna get the part
that really not a red better look in the
news well he's also way better looking
but that's not a good looking guy
doesn't matter a lot of good looking guy
he'll be so much better with him don't
see so much guy was he good-looking when
I was younger
Brad leak okay alright he's got some
people chances beard I told you when he
sweats his girlfriend smelled them never
tell you sir she loves it no she goes he
was leaning out he know him very well
was back in the
and she smelled him his fiancee at the
time and she just uh I go what are you
doing he was due birthday we're on our
way
flying to Nantucket and she goes he
smells like olive oil and he sweats I
was like this [ __ ] smells like
olive oil I bet he does I was like this
[ __ ]
and then he's then you play a board game
with Bradley and he's really competitive
but when you win he goes like this he
goes oh good job dude [ __ ] good Jay
he's like a really good sport
he broke broke up with his girl and now
there's rumors him and Lady gaga right
he broke up with that girl it's not
hottest thing oh my god he bedevil to
who she is delicious The Blade II got
whoo ha whoa but my god she's frustrated
now listen there's someone sick of
[ __ ] beyond theaters name is JC
I'm saying that's just the way it goes
it's true it's just the way the cookie
crumbles in our lives dude
yeah she's dating Lady gaga now here's
the advantage Lady Gaga has over this
she's so hot you know it's frustrating I
don't grind my teeth she's so hot that's
like that's like a what what happens
when you see a Ferrari like you I caught
Brendan [ __ ] trying to he was rubbing
his genitals against his Ferrari I
[ __ ] the exhaust I was like you guys
akin they pull him off his own Ferrari
um yes she's frustratingly hot but
here's the advantage Lady Gaga has is
she just has that it factor done she
she's an artist she's powerful right
she's a bit of a boss she might not look
like her but she has this she has those
ex fact she's undeniable bro charge and
I was not good at everything but
compared to the other girl I mean what
are we talking about here you know I'm
talking I mean but she has factors that
she doesn't that's that's one you've
been there you've dated
[ __ ] Ferraris but there's not much
going on and when you get when you get a
to get a Honda Civic that has a bunch of
tricks up its sleeve you were out of
town Bob yeah I'm super drawn to it
suckers fur for personality the one
thing about my wife who is the [ __ ]
hilarious she always had a great sense
of humor
Scot great sense of humor but when my
son I think is going to be a comic but
yet personality as you get older is
everything yeah cuz you're stuck with
them do as long as they super curvy
that's the I think as soon as long as
they have a personality a huge rack oh
man
you don't say no just kind of crazy
great ass not an equation yeah he's
great yeah but other than that yeah
speaking of which chin still no no
nothing on the dating front for the
whole yeah of course there's Dana hadn't
find these cut Wow dude what are you
gonna do you'll see no I don't see hazy
no changes we'll see he just went you'll
see and anyway he does he looks sideways
do you know when they won eight when
you'll see as a story comes breaking out
that there's seventeen girls trapped in
his basement yeah yeah
what do you mean gah what no what if
he's dating Bradley Cooper's ex that hot
smoke show you never know he's all hey
man let's quit talking about how let's
move on why you talk offensive Jim woody
what are you gonna do though have you
ever thought about it I'm really not
concerned right now you're you're 41 42
I just turned 42 when was your birthday
April do we celebrate nah by the way you
guys for out cat's birthday I did not I
was out of town that texture okay when
was your birthday it was last Wednesday
right the third you [ __ ] I didn't know
that happy birthday don't know it's also
in Hawaii but I do text cat ah
I'm terrible yeah we're bad with
birthdays but you don't bring yours up
[ __ ] you do anyone to know your age I
just don't like people making a big deal
out of it not age I don't care and you
bring up hey but here's the thing chin
what's your plan dude you're 42 and
there are I say this was all due respect
there are no prospects man there is dude
there's prospects but I'm just I'm not
paying to deal with I think you're not I
am
you're a tall handsome not talking about
my looks personality why could you like
to sing and [ __ ] on your own I'm just
super anal about things he doesn't like
change right well honestly being single
is probably one of the my favorite
things right now do you like your alone
time I do yeah yeah because I wasn't
worried about anything
other things about having children and
have yeah see is that you you just
there's nothing like that year you're
not an individual anymore yeah there's
no alone time I like being home and just
not worrying about what are there so but
you can get a girl who's super
independent who's gonna do our own thing
you'll see no no you're waiting for
technology with a panic dinnertime [ __ ]
haha
you'll see I have funny ok not 2040 yeah
but he's trying to figure out like how
to tell us bad you'll see you're trying
to fit you what okay there's definitely
girls but I'm not really like super
there's none that I'm like wow what I
would actually want to spend real time
with no desire to spend time with girls
at all not that I know like an actual
girlfriend
you having fun go out and have fun just
in general dude still do that what I
want you you know you go in group dates
know usually if you guys ever talk to
people that watch the show this is show
and back up our I tell you like whenever
they see me outside I'm usually with
okay yeah yeah don't talk about as a
friend
summer friends yeah yeah I do bad and
Britain and I don't have girlfriends
really that's not how we roll no we're
friends guys ma'am you see is with a gal
it's gonna be trouble someone suck it
like it like if you saw if you saw
Brennan and I out I'm just saying guy
that's my only girlfriend yeah okay so
if you saw Brennan and I out if we were
at dinner with a girl yeah
or we were it be I'm all set I'm French
they better be
they better be a publicist or a business
associate with a notebook in front of
them because otherwise kill some female
column-wise we guilty yeah no it was it
was a woman in his car you know I mean
is it we're guilty guilty
we're guilty full-blown at dinner with
what at a bar what with the guilty I'm
sharing the steak there's a reason
there's a guilty
I you know I'm stressed out about Jim
what are you gonna do do it I honestly
if I want to settle down if I'm just
like tired of being whatever then I have
options I would say what about like but
that's if I just give up on like what
about family and kids like you know you
can do both I don't want that at the end
career I honestly don't want to have
like I don't wanna have a real
relationship right now I don't want kids
I mean maybe one day but I'm not like
one day no bro right I had a kid at what
46 you said I was 41 your lot your
latest kid when your yeah dude his kids
are he said you have like five my second
one was when I was 40 yeah 46 yeah there
you go boom I have 246 man but no my son
seven so 45 45 I had three years that's
a long time I conceived the child I [ __ ]
yep yep and he had a kid before that if
you busted nah Cisco yeah he's busting
nuts
my son was conceived in the hotel Vitaly
yeah brothers graph-like
but you catch brows I here comes the
[ __ ] gift here comes the little guy
you're welcome
that's what I say icing icing yeah yeah
yeah nothing huh I'm surprised that you
guys are so concerned that's sweet
that's very sweet of you
what's alarming to me but I'm fine with
it I think you're just think he's a lone
wolf I like it right now I like it right
now for now you've been out for how long
I think chenna stupid I've been single
for it's hot Bob how long have you been
with us two and a half years you know
you do know that I know that if you ever
came to us and said hey guys just you
guys you know you he and I would not
give a we celebrated I said Chin's like
a no even if he is Brenda and I would
would be your biggest I appreciate that
dude you throw ratings on the show we
would be only one officiate your wedding
I can't go through dudes and get sick I
would marry you at your wedding I mean I
come a little bit and my my to fire you
but you're going to hell but still Jesus
frowned
I always talk about being a cliche your
[ __ ] parade can go somewhere but I'll
celebrate I'm a conservative like I
mamas I'm an economic conservative and I
can't stand left-wing identity policies
well but I'm basically super liberal
social he had me too damn I would marry
and I dunno that's awesome
yeah well it's a belief if it happens
like she's been long you been with us
way long in two and a half years how
long does it make how long we went to
Australia maybe three years longer than
that you've been with us that was when
we remember we left Fox with Wow
I remember the exact date everything
four years ago like if you decided to
leave us for you decided to leave us I
think it would be a disaster for us we
used to yeah we'd completely completely
admit we need you guys thank you
Brian can leave we need to find her you
can trust that we that you really rely
on know that how good your [ __ ] good
we went through a lot of like people you
know do a lot of frogs before we found
our prince you are clockwork reliable
it's [ __ ] not to be like there are
not a lot of people that are like that
they're not a lot of people who are
tough enough to [ __ ] be clockwork
like that agent sounded [ __ ] reliable
yes do I admire it now they were rabble
always said my Koreans are not [ __ ]
[ __ ] Vietnamese no joke the Vietnamese
again I've said it a thousand times no
one has ever conquered Vietnam they've
tried wants to though you know better
land round there I want we should go
there apparently it's great
ah dude that would you find fun yeah too
far to fly so justr cow what do you what
do you think is the verdict gun chin now
you've hung out with a probably more
than us do you remember on the road with
gym buddies very a recluse he's he's
eating sushi out of a market he's doing
his own thing he's an artist we went out
a row too soon though we barely knew
each other so it was like kind of we
want our huge long trip when we barely
dawn yeah it was it was hello it oh why
was it weird oh because I went cold
opened sold out theaters
two-year understand that in Australia
that's not cold open Jesus Christ that's
my training camp yeah if we get naked in
front of us no problem right like we're
just naked yeah and it wouldn't matter
what happens you would not get naked in
front of us right now no no this is not
station culture you ever seen a gut
listen I grew up in lock rooms even when
Asians being locker room they were never
like the wider black guys my god naked
[ __ ] do karate kick everyone's
laugh-in and [ __ ] I've had black guys
use their dicks are talking like mics
it's fun dude
it's one oh right now I've been locking
with agents they ain't doing that now
lyoto machida walks wrong with a
towering you guys I've never seen his
dick disappointing I want to see the
dragon you feel me you feel me you feel
me cuz he's got these guys hat Brazilian
so I know it might be work might be that
big old acai dick cat what do you think
is going on with chin because you you
guys hang out on your own do I think
chin is really picky I think he needs a
very particular type of person and I
don't know if that person exists in our
area do you have any friends are you
John as huh they're gonna be really
young though I don't know if you want
somebody that sure no no you don't want
mature nah I'm my personalized way a
mature I mean around my friends like
close friends really yeah I'll give you
guys are way more mature than me
well on the outside of comedy I mean we
talk about dicks and Asians and I'm so
[ __ ] I'm just showing mature sometimes
you guys have kids so you're mature yeah
that's fair yeah so what do you think
you have no I don't know if I have any
friends that chin would like oh I think
he's just not interested I don't know I
don't know what type of girl he likes
but I feel like she's she's in the she's
somewhere I don't know we're in it
there's like maybe three of them in the
world
[ __ ] three girls that change like that's
the one well that's how your books you
know I'm full chin we don't know but the
ones that date have been awesome
they've been can be awesome cuz you're
single [ __ ] but I was younger but you
won't get on the dating app switch
so much I'm still on tinder I just don't
use it say you're not on it that's like
me on tinder I've never been on there
but I don't use it ray as the [ __ ]
huh it's not for him know what's right
he's not there yet
all right Brian I like my glasses yeah
you have to ha
but there are some [ __ ] dude just
need a profession just be professionals
you do your thing that come over you pay
him dude I would not mind that to be
honest if I'm like feeling super lonely
that seems like the best way just
professionals you can rely on yeah yeah
the same one that comes over bottom
every Friday or Saturday I mean if you
need someone let me know the last place
I worked at a bunch that's true she did
yeah I used to hold the phones yeah the
last weeks I worked at it was just a
bunch of really really well-to-do men
and women who didn't want to have
families didn't want to have
relationships and they would have
escorts and prostitutes come up all the
time really yeah I know a lot of them to
this day most of them are really really
good people no that's the thing a lot
more cool a lot of them are some of the
best people you'll meet a hotter
what are they were they run usually what
are they run I don't know how much they
run I think it also depends on what
you're looking creative for it what if I
had they were rich though those people
right yeah very well-to-do people
they're super Hey three to five if you
if I saw you talking about quality when
we started the show I understand but
three to five is not
I can't just try be Brendan if you solve
for the fight would you give the five
grand you like oh yeah no doubt but
that's a lot of money for the night
a $5,000 beautiful women in my life
there's not that much better
five thousand bring up five grand
Victoria's Bupers ex that that is hot as
[ __ ] but five thousand five grand for
two old Bradley what we care you've been
paid 5 grand for Bradley's very grand
I'm únicos you get you coming around we
come around no no absolutely not all
right three grand see how it starts I'm
taking to my car dealer females
kourt's wait em over to drove yeah let
that can sell that listen that's that's
for the billionaires [ __ ] like that
no I'm talking about real people [ __ ]
dan that the people are in the business
in Hollywood I've seen it dude three
sexy Japanese slim big boobs
$160 I think our Dean if you're looking
for it
Asian Amy now here's the problem with a
lot of these is they look that you think
you're gonna get that and they come over
and it looks like [ __ ] yeah yeah
[ __ ] Isis we're gonna need help
good night that's another sad thing when
a girl goes up and then they come down
like five minutes later like you know
that they were sent away that's I'm like
oh you're the good tough gig man it's a
tough gig yeah I know a girl who guys
spit in her face she went and he didn't
like her and spit in her face and in
Malibu was she talking back though no
she went to be his escort she looks like
Jimmy spinner faith yeah and then she
had some people go visit him and oh they
killed him oh oh wow this story took you
know these extravagant here's the dgn
quit looking at you
here's the thing though I don't have a
problem with this like really hot girl
shouldn't have a problem who put too
much too much too much effort too much
judgment on sex like it's like all right
I think prostitution is basically we go
but it should be legal why not
I don't get it it is it's done any way I
could get my back massage by some hot
girl but she touches a different part of
my body she goes to jail those fights
laws those outdated vice law
yeah the show old school I don't have a
problem with it I just think two
consenting adults should be allowed to
enter into a transaction there is a
transaction anyway there's a transaction
let's say I went on a date tonight let's
say mean cat went out I bought cat
drinks about her dinner they went to a
really nice place
five hundred dollars and then I got a
hotel it's another foot that's a yeah
that's a grand I'm it I'm in for a grand
that money's money without him give it
directly to you or if I'm paying for in
forms of liquor and hotel rooms so it's
still it's just so stupid yeah that's
right yeah that's uh that's that there
are especially as you get older to be my
age you know I was listening to a sex
expert on armchair expert with that in
jeopardy and a sex expert on there and
you know how everyone's like oh like
these Millennials and these young kids
are I'm so much sets and they're
ridiculous and that's not true because
now not having sex right no well the
entire nation especially the United
States is having less and less sex
especially the younger demo because they
have so much access to porn and they and
they do it themselves now and and now
like monogamy is really not for them so
they might hook up here and there but
they're really not [ __ ] with that man
and they're and everything's about
becoming self efficient and you know
that they're having it's a bummer
because there's not that connection
you're able to do it in the cyber way or
something that would well the porn is so
good now or you can do you can chat to a
girl or DMS or the sending nudes so you
know dudes they're like I am jacking off
this way you know so it's it's going
down and down that's a bummer that
doesn't make women happy that's for damn
sure
and maybe the women are the same you
know yeah it's interesting that's
interesting but they talked about like
woods like I don't have any sort of time
oh they're talking about like with with
gay dudes how it's just different for
them right like if you're a gay man you
can go I mean you know well there's
areas you can go and L anywhere in the
world in the nature would in LA and you
go get [ __ ] by four guys and come back
and bike alright where we getting
smoothies that's true well there's no
there's no gym there's no restroom where
four women are gonna let you [ __ ] them
and then carry on with your day so it
just doesn't exist now because dudes
have testosterone it's just what they do
uh-huh it's not that big of a deal
that's dudes are creepy yeah it's
interesting there's a creepy that way
super yeah it's an interesting thing
somebody asked me I was talking about to
people about love and they were asked me
to define
love like what do you mean you're in
love like when you say you're in love
with somebody in a relationship what
does that mean how do you define it
what does that mean and that well how
long is it gonna last if you ever try to
define it it's a tough thing to define
there's actually little action
that's deep there's possession we are
possessive over somebody because that's
your mama bear that's your but-but-but
love is a hard thing to kind of you know
it's like what's the motivation behind
you are in a relationship with somebody
you really love them you you guys are
obsessed with each other I love a lot of
people yeah the question is when you say
you're in love with somebody what is if
you were to really dissect that what's
that really [ __ ] mean you know it's
like that'd be tough way there'd be a
tough to define sometimes maybe it's
best not to define it right so I was
thinking about this the other day like
scientists like to reduce [ __ ] there are
different ways of looking at life they
break it down and so let's breaking it
down takes the magic out of life so let
me give you a classic example I love
dogs I love dogs had dogs my whole life
somebody I heard a scientist that there
was this article about how dogs are
hunters scavengers and pack animals and
when they're really friendly with you
and they wag their tail that might be
how they've evolved to get you to give
them food and take care of them yeah if
you look at a dog as a self-serving
animal that's manipulating you that way
you're not gonna love dogs the same way
when you look at a dog that's just a
[ __ ] beautiful creature that makes
you smile that runs after a ball that
kids hug and cry when it dies that's a
that's and that is a truth that they're
like your deep love for your dog which I
have is a is just as true as what the
scientist is describing as why the dog
like to have love I'm not that
interested in your definition of a dog
yeah that that's not how I look at my
dog I throw in there it is but that
science may not be relevant to me
emotionally and it doesn't make my life
better actually you're very
understanding I guess the deep
scientific mathematical motivations of a
dog and we'll some things aren't
scientifically explained sometimes you
can't really quantify like will quantify
faith there you go any religion give me
the formula where I should believe in
Jesus Christ there you go very religious
Sam Harris who is a public intellectual
will say things like we have to science
has to destroy village
well okay until he does until you lose a
child and then what was your how are you
gonna help me with your science dude I
told you I need like what and that's I'm
not that much of a religious person this
is well-documented I'm a deity your son
I believe in a god but I'm a certain
religion I don't believe Jesus Christ ah
yeah Viet this diat ism so but when my
son got had his issues for Santa to
start praying [ __ ] yeah you the first
dance are doing because you know I
didn't what's the first thing I did
before I hit that curtain start praying
[ __ ] yes there's sewing up there please
help me out
ever hear that there's no no atheist in
a foxhole foxhole meaning like the wood
you in a hole you're about you're in a
war with a you know waiting until you've
been in those situations there is a
reason that you you when you're helpless
when you you have no options when
science isn't there for you you start
[ __ ] prayer but science can explain
that feeling you get when like
inspiration no not that they definitely
unexplained that but science can't
explain that thing where it goes I want
to do that Brennan I'd go here I went
down to I should you start right into it
yeah like that little thing in your
brain go I want to do that yeah I
definitely do that yeah hey man you're
gonna be in trouble so so Charlie get
ready you're gonna be in trouble
Jonathan Hyde who's a psychologist talks
about this exact thing he goes
human beings are intuitive so it's not
you don't just you not just immoral
you're not just moral because it causes
harm so the idea is I'm a moral person I
don't want to cause any harm but we also
have weird intuitions like where we use
these really [ __ ] up examples a woman
takes an American flag cuts up in a
bunch of pieces and cleans her bathroom
with it well we don't like that somebody
takes his [ __ ] on a sacred battlefield
that your nation was founded on we don't
like that somebody [ __ ] a chicken comes
in it cooks the chicken and eats it
nobody gets hurt a vegan a woman she's
got a job creating bodies in a thing she
goes you know this is a perfectly good
waste of meat guys about to go into
incinerator she cuts a piece of his
thigh off takes it home cooks it meets
it
nobody got hurt yeah but we all go oh
yeah we love brother and sister they're
in the woods nobody can see it he wears
a condom she's on birth control they
[ __ ] are they huh nobody knows about it
they're hot but we we haven't no
scultures go
even though nobody got harm technically
it's still not it's still yeah it's
still it illicit Abbas gust response
found at a bar why well that's that's
that intuition human beings are [ __ ]
intuitive and if you want to talk that's
how people vote too they go I don't like
a lot of people were like I just don't
like Hillary Clinton Trump won yeah Oh
yourself about it I don't trust her what
is it about her you ever meet people
will you go I just don't trust that
person I just don't and I've had that
and that I'm usually [ __ ] right
there's something about that person
where I'm like I just don't I don't
believe you I don't know why but I don't
believe you know they're gonna turn
around and walk away like talk [ __ ] yeah
there's something more you're asking
your odeon nice to me because you want
what is hell and that intuition is very
important to listen to oh it's
everything it is some people call it
street smart yeah Rogan had a [ __ ]
riff yesterday on astrology cuz we did
stand-up on the spot
astrology and he goes it's [ __ ] he
goes you just want a pattern like he
went through this whole thing about how
he talks with really smart science I
don't give it away cuz he might turn
into a bit yeah but him but it was so
good because it was like astrology is
for people who want a pattern a
predictable pattern to life but there's
nothing wrong with that it's human but
you can't predict life life isn't a
pattern by fist-fucking though random
it's random yeah he was really funny
last night improvising um goes to I
gotta read I made a giant dong dude can
you help me pull this thing out cuz I
guess man I got him all tied down in my
leg he's been really unruly lately so
yep intuition I get a bad feeling about
this
hey B you know what man I might vote for
Bernie Sanders or or cuz he's getting
rid of student loans or you know I'm
gonna do what you know I'm gonna do if
we're gonna get a real private loan
yeah dude - I'm talking about earnest I
designed a private student loan for
actual students into that 19 I mean you
can apply on your phone dude they
customized loan terms low interest rates
no fees they also give you three extra
months nothing complicated
okay it's less comic air because lot of
guy kids can't afford college or
scholarships
okay earnest is not a private student
loan for actual students from 2000 eyes
I mean you can get apply totally on your
phone you you you have customizable loan
terms low interest rates no fees they
also give you three extra months nine
months total after leaving school to
start paying back your private student
loan and earn its private student loans
can cover up one hundred senator schools
cost of attendance yeah but is it
impossible like you have to take nine
hours of flat paper word no that's the
thing you don't have to have a finance
degree for it and also I'll tell you
something else the internet loves the
earnest customer service they gave it a
nine point four out of ten on trust pot
dude I love it it's a two-minute
eligibility check you can invite a
cosigner if you choose to and apply yep
and guess what the school year is
approaching fast so the final kid
listeners you guys get a hundred dollars
cash bonus when you get a private
student loan at earnest comm slash
fighter that's a hundred dollar cash
bonus you get a private student loan at
earnest comm slash fighter and you can
see the terms and conditions on the site
go to earnest comm slash fighter today
don't let student loans stand in your
way take control with earnest EI r n est
comm slash fighter where were we at for
it to drain that thing um I don't know
it's just some kinda these are watching
change things no I don't watch that dumb
show oh really
yeah but my daughter is obsessed it's
good anyone else in here watch it
anymore you just watch the first season
or season yeah this might be the best
season man I'm probably get back is it
really good we're so well done really so
well done so should I watch it I don't
care yeah that's a great answer right
good show though I've watched it it's so
well done scary no I'm 36 min there you
go
you know not very scary but that's not a
scary show it's just a really well done
show it's really really cool but
euphoria is the [ __ ] finally caught up
last night
euphoria on HBO I don't know you don't
talk about pushing the limit what is
your shot well it's with the
a day a girl zendaya zendaya she's
gorgeous vitamin yeah she plays a drug
addict and yeah but there's then there's
this transgender girl in this as well
it's just I mean there's a lot of dicks
in this thing maybe I like it but
there's like then there's this married
man who's [ __ ] this transvestite like
there's a lot going on a real-life [ __ ]
going on dude
it's yeah I mean yeah I've never seen
something shot like this and so it dives
in deep deep cuts into the the lives of
like drug addicts and transsexuals it's
so well done men damn there's some good
TV out there man
yeah this show so goddamn good and that
the sings and dies I would do everything
she can sing she can dance she could
really do it on she's such a monster 900
originally from Oakland billion fans on
Instagram but the transgender girl on
the left real transgender was I was like
oh is that like a girl or about a
journey I was a dude that was a dude
that's now a female but that's that's
her in real life because I watch like
behind the scenes thing because I was
trying to figure out is that a female
playing in a transgender or as a male
player nope that's a real transgender
female who's an actor huh paint a lot of
roles for them I know so she definitely
yeah it's very interesting
beautiful endangered Jules Jules all
right yeah old is she I don't know dude
why I just did 20 Hunter Schafer's the
real name when did she get transgender
woman she's known for a rose Jules HBO's
drama she's really really good man
really really freaking good you know who
else is in the show is a shut up House
daughter she'd have like a big role but
she's in it um you dig the show that's
okay it's super interesting because I've
never seen some [ __ ] like this you know
drug addicts and transgender in high
school and hooked it up with married man
not crazy [ __ ] and rah
yeah all right let's do some crab okay
okay all right first one you guys know
about this I think more kind of sorcery
a video of it so it's a Howard Stern is
in to on 13 that you guys know this AMA
Howard Stern dammit every day I'm a huge
Howard Stern fan so this one kind of
bums me out but it's like he's doing
when they first went to Sirius or
somebody's like doing a company retreat
and he's talking up there and god he's
so cocky and saying how you know how he
made Jerry Seinfeld and how they should
create fake accounts go back let me read
this says there yeah so the Sanford
crops happened the pilots may hit TV the
meetings called the summit which he did
in 2013 where we're gone and how we're
getting there the self-proclaimed king
of all media well that's what he is
Jason wasn't the only slight which the
shock jock claimed to have created
notoriety you don't have to regulate
Billy Corgan even referenced well we
have on no no quarter director this is
the core Smashing Pumpkins okay yeah not
the [ __ ] documentaries yeah you just
see yeah the part that I saw it's just a
bummer if you're a [ __ ] Howard Stern
fan like it's so Hollywood where he was
like so anti Hollywood keeps going down
he somebody puts out a rock book a rock
record we are the place to go the Pope's
don't think or care about us some do but
most don't we get the same results but
we don't have a book club he's referring
to Oprah he's saying he's just as big as
Oprah but what's weird you it's all true
right mm I mean in other words his
influence and his ability to get you
exposure is 100 percent of fact yeah as
far just the bragging about it that
sucks yeah but look he was Adam Levine
owes us he was the nobody was leaking
for him before the voice it yeah I think
the the the bummer is just came as a
rogue in him sort of him sort of
bragging about his influence but he also
goes like he goes he was you know every
slurry does my show since the best
interview they've ever done and it's
just like very like it's just a bummer
if you're Stern Finn yeah well it might
be the match nations behind like a lot
of times you don't want to see how a
sausage is made but you like sausage
like you know they like again you have
to be a bit of a killer my experience
with people like this is they're killers
behind the scene the killers I mean they
they get like Tom Hanks one time said I
let people think I'm a nice guy
but but he's getting what he wants you
know your your you're getting good what
have you heard about Ellen I just raised
on Ellen
yeah don't you savage dude tough SAP oh
yeah and by the way hey you just full-on
comic doesn't mostly at all the most
savage there's no room for Oh she'll rip
your [ __ ] head off
but she's dancin hey let's give out this
but dude on behind scenes they say she
is a murderer but she knows what she
wants and and she knows how to get there
and I've heard that too she's not pods I
don't people that worked with her yeah
yeah but Barbra Streisand was always
known to be difficult but Barbara says
when walk in listen to a track and go
get rid of the second horn what how'd
you know he's not doing this job I don't
need that you want to be in Barbra
Streisand's band you have to be the best
of the best that guy sucks see that's a
little different though like that I
don't know it's just a bummer yeah well
I think he's a guy who is still doing it
at a high level because he's got a hole
he can never fill and that requires a
certain amount of uncompromising
difficult you know I'm gonna get even
because you're snubbing me but that's
what drives him but he was always liked
by Hollywood then when you listen this
Ray like ah [ __ ] dude I used to be
against all this stuff now you're you
you become that yeah yeah I don't know
I'm still a huge fan probably I can
reason I never listened to him I don't
know much about him I've never listened
to one I've he's amazing I listen to one
interview and it was really good with
Bill Maher but I I need to get it but
that was it yeah he's so good he's so
good
yeah the talk was just like oh man
that's a bummer
yeah real bummer what can you know he
suggested that his people make fake
Twitter accounts to get the word out and
damn dude all right you know his voice
sounds really really like crisp and and
deep and everything he he doesn't on
purpose - he has a specific mic a very
expensive teal I'm Mike oh really I need
he does accuse it compresses it a
certain way so it sounds like so his
voice is there like you all you hear is
yes boys yeah like the
gasps sounds whatever but his is very
light it like ingrained in your mind
wow that's smart yeah I mean if you're
being serious which I have he has its
own floor now it's all yeah I mean he
he's he's ownership in serious yeah I
was thinking about the amount of hate he
must have got when he went from
terrestrial radio to payment structure
or serious yeah he must have got so much
[ __ ] hate good I guess you know he
doesn't really deal with social media
and stuff like that and he tried to do
like a Facebook live or read it live and
said he was on there for two minutes was
like holy [ __ ] like this is so talked to
think that bail out reddit is I get
people tell me don't go on reddit dude
you get [ __ ] a lot of hate oh my god
I don't give a [ __ ] I don't I won't go
on reddit don't worry but I also I don't
care what are you like you don't know me
I do the best I can to be good but but
also I mean yeah I mean are you on
reddit creating accounts it against
those people that hate you sure all
right okay well well no because you're a
famous actor comedian making millions of
dollars no no one's who's successful is
on reddit do it writing both yeah do you
know anyone who's successful that got on
a comment and wrote something negative
about I don't want anyone read it
especially you've done a podcast you've
done anything you know one comic I have
work you think Kevin Hart's on there
like dude that [ __ ] it's stuck well I
hope ur or Rogen one that you don't care
that's for that's for the the sheep no
this was sheep do what us yet Jim first
one should we describe it I sent this
one the cat so it's some beautiful young
lady and her boyfriend sent this to me
there's a real monkey problem out here
well as this yeah play it
this is a micro rapport poster this by
the way so monkey attacks on people
I guess happened more and more
frequently increasing problem in
northern India check that off the list I
would [ __ ] I would come there look at
them I'd get a bat and bash those
[ __ ] monkeys in their head I'll teach
you to think if you got kids I'll teach
them where the [ __ ] bosses so frightened
see how this get has the terrible
problem but oh here they go that's oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
and then they knocked up down there
biting the end their teeth would [ __ ]
her dude alright I mean let me grab you
your [ __ ] this makes me angry
does it yep I'll [ __ ] kick you in the
face you dumb monkey [ __ ]
386 monkey attacks were last year
alright go dude oh [ __ ]
we'll just imagine if you have kids yeah
but I would [ __ ] am I just get myself
a 22 and shoot your face maybe I'm dude
I'm telling you there's a real coyote
problem where I live dude at 4:00 in the
morning they get together and it's like
Lion King they shout at the top of their
lungs
last night they might being killing
someone's dog cuz I heard a very loud
crying that one away and then all the
Coyotes were gone that's it I'll kill
those monkeys easily problem is that
they are yeah their habitat is is [ __ ]
up no one else is a problem in India you
know what else comes in Oh
tigers and cobras leopards tigers the
big problem in India uh yeah but not oh
sit down not in so in Mumbai and the
biggest city leopards cuz it leopards
they come cuz I know they have a tiger
problem too yeah
Tigers you know alligators are the real
prize you see how many people died here
from alligators you know
in Florida I don't know why I was
looking this up no all over the word
dude crocodiles alligators cracked up
some real problem rock and ice don't
from dude a real problem
yeah type in [ __ ] uh leopard attacks
in the in villages Jesus Christ but
alligator attacks or crocodile attacks
crocodiles alligators big mouths are a
big problem in Africa
duder problem all over and they I mean
they're vicious dude well that - yeah I
think they have a fight of crocodiles
sure man it's a real [ __ ] problem
worldwide that you've talked about
thousands of attacks dude
thousands oh yeah look at this well over
5,000 attacks half of them are murder
dead
hold on oh really yeah cuz they they
they will kill you
dude it's a real problem I didn't
realize how bad [ __ ] I was on 206 it's
the salt water Quattro 505 look at so
just last year alone over a thousand
alligator crocodile attacks in America
dead Egypt the Nile six down in the
middle of Africa 693 scroll over did the
King scroll over to America on that map
chin saltwater crocodile because the
rest of your thousand 264 did you know
that is that big of a problem I didn't
know I was watching I forget I was
watching something like [ __ ] CNN or
some [ __ ] for 19 fatal deaths last year
from white [ __ ] Krakatoa crocodiles
dude hold on where do I see that in
America yep that's America right there
well then it goes down to Mexico down
there really well that'd be a hundred
and go to the nine Lord alone because
math is working correctly which way over
to 99
yeah what is that that's Florida dude
look at all that those are crocodiles
yep yep yep 2013 all attacks outcome
non-fatal real problem though innit [ __ ]
yeah I never thought there'd that big of
a deal now listen if I'm anywhere in
that side of the the United States you
ain't seen me in any body of water
there's nothing hmm I don't know if this
is just for that 2018 it's just like all
over the place yeah you know I'm seeing
another [ __ ] problem what else you got
chin weathers that
next one yep
okay so we're is now gonna have a new
system in place where you can go to over
comfort which is gonna be for their
higher-end cars where you can put on
quiet mode whether you don't want to
have a conversation with the driver
you're open to having conversation or
you don't have a preference as well as
what temperature you're gonna want the
car to be whether you want it cold or a
little warmer but whether you want music
playing or not as well as weather yeah
they're putting a lot of really great
things into over like helping you with
your luggage from the airport little
things like that or if you want a card
that has more leg room in the back for
you you're a bigger person see my thing
is is I don't want to help with my
luggage I'm not a I'm not chick I don't
help with my luggage just open the back
don't talk to me and put on music that's
my ideal uber yeah and get me there the
also dropped me off not at the passion
to drop off drop me off at arrivals also
drive a little faster than speed
absolutely illegal now that's why they
don't do it some doing hell gangster
ones disaster this people also drive
faster but also drive fast yeah I like
fast drive and don't be stupid yeah what
else you guys driving fertility clinic
this was so crazy what happened here
this isn't so there's a couple from New
York who couldn't get pregnant and they
ended up going to this fertility clinic
one of the best ones here in California
and all over the country they ended up
finding out that when she gave birth she
gave birth to two beautiful boys that
were not Asian and the couple was Asian
both were Asian and white kids they
don't know they don't specify what the
kids were but they were not Asian both
parents are Asian they pay to have their
embryos placed into the woman but they
accidentally put two embryos from two
different people into her do you know
I've told you I've even technically
related with the IVF co2 IVF and I made
two deposits on my bust busting
yeah I busted in it and when I left I
thought I'm if they keep that and use it
with other people
Oh we'd have no idea the question yeah
of course they were right I'm healthiest
slot max so what happens to them well
right now they're suing cuz one she
carried the children to term - she had
to give the children back to the
biological biological parents also
didn't know that this was gonna happen
so now they both have to have sons and
those sons are asked if you could if you
were looking for a job
we'll take this now they are your child
yeah it's crazy so now they're suing the
clinic for emotional damages they're
gonna get him everything's yeah and now
they're trying to figure out what
happened with their embryos because they
actually wanted to have girls and
originally when they I guess extracted
the embryos that they were gonna use
they specifically chose just girls but
the wife heard something a little odd
when they put the embryos inside her
because they said these are both they
referred to the embryos as boys and she
just kind of shrugged it off she didn't
think too much of it the day of she
ended up having two boys that were not
Asian easy that'd be so hard Bri how
that's nine months nine whole months to
the IVF tool again I looked into it with
my girl cuz we're gonna have twins
before we made it happen naturally dick
games on point for two boys who wants
kids him yeah naturally who wants a boy
I'll bust in your face so hey it's
really expensive be the success rate
ain't great on those IDs
all right that's a very expensive every
time you have to do it yeah man my
doctor was such a tool to owe me the
jeebies yeah my buddy he did my buddy
Joey dr. Kardashian's him Oh
my buddy just stem cells in his shoulder
shoulders and he'd been paying for like
15 years he goes dude it's two years now
it's been gone completely yeah it really
does work I'll hold on give me a second
ya know 2016 with stems really yeah oh
yeah no no Brian just found out okay
that good they'll brought yeah your
friend Joe Rogan's been doing it for
seven years yeah but okay thank you
every fighter and every athlete I know
does it thank you
click but I didn't know now what they're
doing though is there's a new procedure
that's gonna get like approved they're
taking the amniotic fluid from a woman's
like second trimester or something those
stem cells become yours if that you get
they'll shoot you into your bloodstream
and they can mutate into becoming yours
and they become anything that you want
them to be so they they will be whatever
you need them to be essentially it's
kind of crazy so that there's this is
the news oh yeah let's go hair loss hair
loss hair loss hair loss and she didn't
get on that old daddy is a little sore
and I'm achy I'm pushing a little hard
with the boxing slash lifting shoulders
are given out are they giving out little
danger there aids off there a key my
shoulders are a Kinney CBD oil dude yeah
they're hurt inflammation CBD oil yeah I
know a guy who owns the company
maybe I should warm up better to don't
do that now or not or you know if do you
know I was just part of being 52 yeah
CBD oil would definitely help with that
inflammation rowdy all day all right
I'll take only charge you have what else
who yet so there is a new trend of
people doing bigger and better gender
reveals and there's one gender reveal
that happened in Australia that went
wrong
and it's going to I reveal things always
weird my girl talk about doing general
reveal with our new kiddo it's like I
have what are we gonna do band I even
throw how does that work the mom knows
but the father doesn't know so so no one
knows but the doctor so you can pay for
it right it's like $200 more and they do
the blood and then they go what we want
to do with the results and we said send
it to her brother Steven I got a mint
hole throw the surprise birthday but all
that main surprise gender-reveal party
that's all we wide him just as he went
well should we wait to the weekends
they're like a big reveal party meant no
[ __ ] no as soon as you find out here a
text me what it is and I'll pretend I'm
surprised be come over with like a blue
cupcake or yet a pink cupcake that's
what we did you are you chummy
video of you finding out your girl was
pregnant
doing what first time well the first
time yeah dude that was so long ago as I
got done doing UFC tonight oh my god yes
I've been blown up on my girl Mike what
the [ __ ] man
and she's like we're yeah we're on Mike
chill [ __ ] - and then I get back and
she's like well I have news very strange
huh I go like this to him one time I go
hey man hey listen you guys are just
dating
don't be getting her pregnant I know how
you are don't be getting all like bro
man taking the anybody just [ __ ] just
take it easy
what's work to be done and I just saw
you go now this thing to me something's
gonna happen [ __ ] a month later thank
God yeah but what else is foot how about
how about when I you know she calls her
she's Mexican as [ __ ] she calls her
family they flip out their crime like
let me call mine now me call mine get my
dad my dad my dad didn't know my girl at
the time at all so I go dad
you're gonna be a grandpa we're gonna be
a grandpa huh we got it we got one on
the way he's here silence it's on
speaker silence at well you know you
don't have to go through with it it's
something like dazzle thank you know you
sound yet you sound thrilled I will cut
you know what he actually he said he
knew you knew you were listening he's
just [ __ ] around she started crying
here hell yeah oh wait he's just joking
no he's funny like no he's joking he's
always joking alright that thank you you
don't know how those things are gonna go
I tell my mother I think the best I'm
getting married where I'm driving I'm
telling I'm getting married and I'm
looking for a ring and it's like big
news your only son is getting married
she goes well be careful because there
are a lot of fake diamonds out there and
some of the diamonds are so fake even or
can I go are you [ __ ] my that you're
worried about that in this shape
heartbreaking um you know JJ doesn't get
up for anything I know you may be an
uncle
I got a kid on the way I just get a text
back cool that's great
well some families are just not that
sentimental or sometimes you just don't
know it like you expect it to be a
bigger
like yeah we know growing up horse show
was the car in my family so I bought a
Porsche before anyone else I called my
dad on the spirit Papa he's like yeah
I'm like your son just bought a 911
Carrera
and he goes silent silence you get the
you get the turbo or is it the is it the
S uh no just a base-model nine let me
guess
well one day well that's like my man
yeah hella good nice click I had a
girlfriend who had a father who [ __ ] a
lot of different women and and once a
year all the all the brothers and
sisters who came from different moms
would get together was this guy on it
was all like yeah if you see him he was
a stud he was my girlfriend was such a
stud back in the day she was like just
like this she was Mexican and Spanish
and and her father was I [ __ ] Spanish
conquistador a spanish matador stud
barrel-chested muscular and obviously
women love them so like one of the
things that his brother says he could
throw a [ __ ] from his knees he was a
catcher and could throw a ball like
[ __ ] to the outfield just really big
and strong and just an alpha male
so he's is all the kids would be there
and I came for all the family reunion
and there was one brother who was so
desperate to have a family and and he
would try to make here we go guys you
guys first time I did he gets hosting
guys listen we don't see each other that
much or a family we love you dad dad
thank you for being here and stuff just
dads like alright so it takes the
morning outside he goes guys alright
guys man it's so good to have you guys
hey let's do this let's do this again
yeah alright and then like this here
comes around me goes guys it's quite a
toast dad hey John we get it John we get
it that everything is all great around
here we don't need another toast
alright weekend he literally shut this
[ __ ] guy that guy's probably 35
nothing and a guy I marry just feels
right
I said to my girl go how what was he
like his daddy he'd show up once a year
Hey like he'd have some press and
simulate yeah yeah and that's how we all
grew up with him he just wanted a dad
that's [ __ ] hilarious off so how did
they anyway how'd they do so they had
special tires that would then produce
this like blue or pink smoke and they
drove their hyped about it putting it on
social media
only lawrence loaded because of it Jesus
crazy
yeah they ended up running in to grab
the passenger and the driver no one was
hurt the driver ended up being arrested
for it because he did this on just a
regular street in Australia
life is funny man well it's like did you
do the one cup a couple did the
gender-reveal party that started all the
forest fires they show here it's mm-hmm
do you see that one
no general parting shots singing with
fires and that was one of the reasons we
had horrible files or how about right
yes that's yours onna remember the
horrible fires in Arizona it's cuz from
a gender-reveal party look at this and
that started like a [ __ ] look
forty-seven thousand acres burned eight
million dollars of damages Jesus that
kids can be like Jesus Christ dead oh no
the kid Phoenix but I name the kid be a
great name oh my god I've gotta do
something the kids singed way go the
Phoenix is good though switch other from
I'm a virgin wildfires Phoenix doesn't
matter spark I name the kid damage oh
boy yes just life man how about that
couple again they're crazy cars you
gotta know what you're doing it's a
bummer but it's life is funny it
happened years ago somehow it's funny
couple got married and was out front
celebrating oh the grandpa bottom is
dream car it's a Viper all cool 500
horsepower 500 pounds of torque
six-speed not really a car for a newbie
gets in it yeah why
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] know what from happy
to you're like just like what the [ __ ]
to the end at least you died like
together that famous that famous [ __ ]
story about the two brothers who carry
their mother all the way to like for 40
miles that did to show their love of
their mothers who the temple so she can
pray and then God asked her what what do
you want for your son you know for your
two sons and she goes for my two sons
never to suffer a day in their life and
the sons took a nap and they never woke
up from the nap Wow and that's well
that's what you asked I don't know what
sparked this it's so random but when I
was come back from vacation we flew in
on United flew back on Delta so I
[ __ ] parked my car at United land and
Delta so you know you gotta walk from
terminal 3 to terminal 7 well I got mama
with me I got my son Tiger with me so I
made them walk but I'm holding all their
luggage and it's I don't know 100
degrees that were walking you know my
son's you know my girls on my son I'm
holding we're taking turns and then
something I don't know why this is so
random I don't want done the story but I
start thinking well this is how like the
refugees feel except from exascale only
like walking on top my shoulder that's
burning so bad some 3-hundred fasciitis
and then I'm holding my son I got all
the luggage and I'm sweating profusely
that's what it's not long every day for
them I and I went I went you know I'll I
probably I better shoes than then though
cuz I was complaining and then I
wouldn't this mine sound like [ __ ]
refugee here we go so my girl goes why
he's so serious I would be like
something about being a Mexican refugee
right now crossing the border that's why
but not hired a coyote to get us across
but you know what did let me tell you
something they call it that's called
empathizing and also one of the things
is my shoulders burn I thought thinking
for mom had to [ __ ] and they do have
all their [ __ ] so my fight and that's
our thing what would I get rid of my
back if I was then what would I get rid
of what what do I have in there that I
wouldn't want to carry yeah and my wife
went down to the border with a bunch of
people to help the kids
this dude pushed his daughter as
multiple sclerosis for three months in a
wheelchair and and was sleeping with her
because they wouldn't separate them
because he they couldn't and she was
looking in his eyes and she was like
this is what this [ __ ] dude did and
and say whatever you want about the
border and stuff I don't believe I'm
aggressions a problem we do need oh but
I think you may know we're doing well
but and so I'm saying is that when you
wouldn't you think about one of these
about educating yourself about the world
and about history it makes you more
compassionate dude it just does cuz you
go you know what I did what I did I
stopped writing my tracks or didn't over
X and [ __ ] guys over at ACF that's
right I called a little service Alec not
today
I have no went straight to my I have a
very wealthy friend who was in a [ __ ]
up their names and they were in this
huge line in Miami like this crazy it
was a it was like it was gonna be a day
wait and he's got one money and he goes
well I'm gonna spend fifty four thousand
dollars like I would yeah we have the
same friend yeah yeah I know buddy time
oh man you know yeah we got weird that's
what triggered like I was gonna like you
can't stop now on a sweating let's see
him being a Mexican immigrant yeah yeah
and I took my foot my shoes off and
start walking barefoot and there you go
and that's legit and the more you learn
about history the more the more you
learn about the world and how people
have to live like in Syria wherever it
might be
it does make you a lot more humane it
makes you more compassion well that did
them and I like to think I'm Chinese
makes you work great what did that I
think I'm Chinese a lot of Chinese
people there no no it's just you know
they're like all compact like sardines
and like this yeah
so I'm groupies myself as a Chinese man
yeah wherever Matt just did I like to go
different ethnics gotcha in this city's
gotcha you're you're a shapeshifter
I just like to put myself in their shoes
you know gotcha shapeshifter now are you
a closet racist are you I'm pretty out
about it you know
okay okay I'm gonna have to move us we
got cast with this this right here so
Jaden Smith this sunshine although weird
you bring him up why keep going all
right okay so he just turned 21 this
past Sunday and he has been getting into
a lot of different philanthropy
causes he has a water company called
just water he's donated a couple of
water filter systems to Flint Michigan a
shitload a [ __ ] yeah he's really to help
Flint machine really helping out it's
really cool yeah
on Sunday for his birthday he actually
bought out a food truck called it I look
the I Love You restaurant and he fed
people on Skid Row
um fresh vegan meals good friend he's
really a fascinating kid he a he's a
huge musician
ops he's the son of Will Smith and Jaden
Smith but what is philantropy with the
water and this stuff it's pretty cool
man
he gets a lot of hate but he's also huge
I kiss about his one song they came out
with has been streamed over a hundred
million times like he's a talented
artist he's but you know he's into
fashion like he's kind of doing his own
thing man yeah it's pretty cool
it's so weird he brought this up
yesterday I wanted this weird wrapped a
whole last night like 2:00 in the
morning on Jaden Smith good-looking kid
I used to see him a lot him and his
daughter super good look I mean his
sister got a super consistent beautiful
but it's interesting with uh it just how
damn good Will Smith is that social
media like you know you can learn from
these guys I went to Will Smith's
Instagram that went to his YouTube page
and he's so good at it man he's so
goddamn good at it hmm
I'm a fan of Jaden Smith man it's great
you know I got because I out Will Smith
posted was I can't believe a Deans 21
and posted a video and I get kind of
teary eyed cuz my son he puts a video
when Jaden was like 2 to 21 and he's
like Jane's on his shoulders it's so
[ __ ] cute man that's it's so cute
it's a - it's the middle one that there
is yep was he he was in pursuit of
happiness
look there is that oh that's just for
second job by the way never acted but
feels awesome in it you know how you got
that gig they couldn't find the role and
he goes papa I'll do it
you got a dream
you gotta protect it want to see his
movie you go race you happiness it will
bring you to tears I've seen it no it's
a true story live bro I know I do I'm an
[ __ ]
cuz he's that movie will make you cry
special PF kids Will Smith you seen
Shawn dude don't give me okay so I'm
gonna watch that tonight I just and I'm
gonna watch tomorrow and start crying
he's so good right
that's he'll be who go back her chin kid
is so cute
oh dude he soaked keeps going down
[Music]
mm-hmm yeah maybe scroll up there was a
montage yeah I was like whole video him
of his son and it was so cool this guy
probably is yeah that's right that's
what it is oh yeah there you go look at
this like that's tiger right now
[Music]
Jing is 100% really surprised and proud
and terrified of how my face makeup
dude he sells a shitload of tickets to
and the boys can dance dance oh [ __ ] to
him and his dad first time they perform
together it's so cool man
you can dance huh God life goes fast man
Leo cute that kid is he's so cute
[Music]
that cool though I bet yeah by the way
ah Jaden his wife would you had a
Pinkett Smith Jaden Pinkett she doesn't
look like she takes me [ __ ] either she
runs a house with her she's killing it
too with her new show yeah via the red
table great table if I shoot that from
Will's house okay I see the daughter the
daughters became an altar willow willow
yes she's your girl holder she uh I
wanted to be like 19 she's good good
good gorgeous yeah look at her hard she
draws alright she's super gorgeous she
dressed super emo my stomach but if she
wanted to shut the damn down yeah
or she could order it all down oh she
she was like oh you want to put on a
dress let's do it yes shut it all down
she could have been such a huge pop star
too because she had one hit when she was
younger I don't know she didn't want to
do it anymore now they don't want to
well well I mean Jaden's doing the damn
thing yeah his days exclude fashion she
you know he was you know what's good
Lord how old is she before I get that
hot
hey but yeah 19 all right we're good um
but you know what's crazy about Jaden is
you know he was
oh she's 18 no with this legal with I
don't want to sound too creepy
but with Jaden you know he was the model
for the Louis Vuitton female oh he
modeled the female like it yeah I think
he's considered pansexual whatever the
case I like it all talk to fine mean
[ __ ] what else you got you
let's go with this Malik McDowell used
to play for the sale Seahawks
this is a cop I guess he was just
driving down the street it was a snowy
day and then he spun out of control so
the cop wanted to pull him over and I
guess test him and he was just being
like you know good we get away from
while your supervisor he says supervisor
a million times the the NFL player yeah
it's a very long video so I'll just show
you parts of it so this is one the pop
so he was drunk he wanted two times he
was over two times the legal limit so he
was drunk yes he was drunk yeah so his
speeding you splat so I'll just show you
the parts that are interesting here
thank you Jim
oh yeah storms just want God that guy's
huge
look at that poor ladies up all morning
the cops trying to trip him
good luck tasing this giant man yeah
I'll check this out he's lucky to shoot
him was he chasing him right now
now yeah you'll see we'll do a countdown
to cops defense he's warned him several
times is there any way you could just
have wait till the cops his friends come
so he stays there now check this out it
doesn't care dude he's like you didn't
shoot him they're they're the size of
these enormous yeah he's so lucky this
cop in shootings is I know he is but
he's now like a hitting the cop he's
just like get away from me get away he
didn't do a damn thing for big guys
tasers ain't gonna do it what the [ __ ] I
think we [ __ ] that just got a mad and
then check out the backup that arrives
I'm sure are they tiny - oh that's it
there I would be so bummed out yeah if
you wanted to do anything you want you
could do anything yeah he's smart enough
not to be fighting well not to let him
just sit there they have done I would
let him sit there yeah just let him sit
just let me sit there because well he's
done this before - he's been like super
like again so lucky he didn't get shot
though
yeah see he's very very lucky he's a
free agent I would have said bro come on
please six three hundred pounds and
insanely athletic do a 23 did that taser
I went in it and just the bear what's
interesting if those cops didn't have
guns they could not stop him do seven of
them can't stop no they couldn't
no but bro they have to that's nuts that
that [ __ ] taser did [ __ ] all [ __ ] all
to him he got up it was a real taser -
not the one that you just put on
go away but that maybe didn't go on a
skin it might have just hit his clothes
I think this guy's a strong clothing
yeah they can't Kim it's not beer skin
they shoot through anything those things
go Wow your sea legs right now you see
when they taser cops right they do to
cops so they know what they're doing and
seen the guy when they shake and he [ __ ]
his pants
no he goes turn it's obvious he starts
laughing when flavius I just [ __ ] my
pants they tell you not to eat before
like the night before for yeah this
guy's peed and [ __ ] his pants in front
of his buddies oh boy he was happy they
stopped shooting he starts laughing
because I still blown away that guy just
went he looked at anyone get this [ __ ]
off me and being out of different
fighting isn't could have gotten shot
though that's the problem
yeah yeah it was good you can do that
that's done it before too you resisted
before that's the kind of [ __ ] cops deal
with all the time [ __ ] thank God that
cop don't have a huge ego I would have
been yeah thank God for that cop
shout-out to that cop for not having a
shell because they're cocky wake up yeah
well I would have been with a guy like
that I would have been little do it or
not alright sit there just calm down
please just don't make my job I'd like
to do - it a little people coming your
optical you know you interested right
all right chill there yeah all right
what else next one all right ASAP Rocky
very very famous rapper he was in Sweden
and then the first Vito came out it
looks like him and his crew were beating
up these two guys alright so I'll show
you a little bit of this first
I'm a ASAP Rocky fan yeah he does
everything I must also to Indy or I
think so you'll see right around here
they're beating up these guys alright
and he's actually sad rocky tossing this
dude damn he tossed the [ __ ] I'm me
and that is punching him there this is
in Sweden yeah yeah but what were those
guys doing
yeah so the ASAP steam released their
own video of what powered this even
started and it's these guys constantly
berate him like just following them and
just annoying them they like call him
then we don't know they just
he seems like you just saw drugs or
something
it up oh they said we don't want any
problem and you guys just keep calling
him chief following them and then they
actually this dude the one that's the
closest he throws his headphones at the
bodyguard this wide like real thing so
you'll have to have bodyguards this is
this oh wow so this guy's trying to hit
the bodyguard throws his headphones out
him see it [ __ ] that dummy up you put a
piece of [ __ ] he's again he's like that
bodyguards cool what's that little dude
think is gonna happen so he's trying to
de-escalate the situation is that a
surprise oh wow because you hit him with
your headphones
these guys are turkish and these guys
are fans of ASAP I don't know that's
Swedish these guys are immigrant area
they're immigrants they're from
somewhere in the Middle East I think I
don't know what's going on or why
they're this right this and they just
won't leave the bone leave them alone
and then some other witnesses come by
that speak their language and tell me oh
yeah tell them that something
so they're falling The Bodyguard right
now we're dudes man people are [ __ ]
boy here and then he walks back and the
guys still come out him again so these
are women are the ones that translate
for them to meet we're our bodyguards
out of the shape she's just caught him
on his head those girls are Somali I
think Utah you guys are talking [ __ ]
earlier through the headphones
we think that is right you placed my
camera even you can't I can't you can't
do that dude
yes I can no you can't do you'd be sued
up the Union that's why you pay
bodyguards so he set Brockie shouldn't
got involved it'd be tough not to though
not to just a [ __ ] punching another
hardest on especially in international
territory so that last guy doesn't know
witness he goes that those guys one of
them slapped my ass and my girlfriend's
ass last time so they're troublemakers
for sure right and now because of this
this is a [ __ ] ASAP Rocky's in jail and
the hell they like they're gonna hold
him for two weeks you're supposed to
hold for three days max but they're all
in for two weeks that is so frustrating
and it's apparently they said there's
rumors that it's a really really crappy
situation there the but his lawyers
saying is not that bad but still he's
held there
that's so part of his team's held there
too if you want to get put in jail sweet
yeah and that's so jacked up but he's in
jail with a lot of people from not from
Sweden yes so sweet so Sweden took in a
lot of immigrants from the Middle East
they said Ron I'm I've tried his best
side to not do anything he's in jail and
not the other guy the guys on Joe did
you see the guy [ __ ] with Ben Askren
no you didn't see the drunk fan [ __ ]
with Ben a stirring the forest fight no
trenee trying to eat art like oh [ __ ]
that's kind of stuff let's end on this
one that's kind of services so
exhausting this [ __ ] makes me want to
take those Dudesons Oh what do you see
those heads
what do you see this look at this guy
[Applause]
[Music]
this dude exhausting exhausting
he just wants to poke a bear and see
what it's like one quick last thing
imagine beat that just look at it
oh dude see that violent move what is
that is that Calvin if you know the
movement you know on time out the movie
uh mmm it's a horror game it's a
terrible name Gyllenhaal in it yeah see
scare it's a moth with tentacles and
hair on tentative tracks like that -
this remorse - oh god what is it dude
it's something called Genghis moth does
it bite I'll they hurts people I don't
like it do you know I don't kill any
animals I'll let my son kill animals
like to kill Knights or anything right
oh this is creepy dude a [ __ ]
centipede like when those big old
centipedes had to kill him they should
all die I know I had to kill him you
kill a centipede I have to step on my
say why cuz we don't kill animals just
Papa why Rock fat that thing is sting
yeah and I just can I use my bug assault
to slaughter flies then another [ __ ]
one that kills big bugs oh really she
shoots salt hard I mean [ __ ] hard it
isn't so you hear oh [ __ ] shook you hear
shook shook in my house a fly's gonna
[ __ ] die I want flies in here I'm
gonna plasma windows I worship the devil
that makes sense
speak of worshipping the devil I'm in
Cincinnati this Friday and Saturday -
shows Friday to show Saturday funnybone
summer vibe come on out since a I'll be
my Petros red jersey with the sleeves
cut off dick hanging out the front
Cincinnati funnybone Friday Saturday
with Derek and a son and then next
weekend I'm in India at the helium in
Indianapolis and then Nashville zany's
August 1st through the 3rd those
stickers almost rolled out and then also
almost sold out Portland August 15 to
the 17th so get your tickets right now t
fat K calm
Cinci see you this weekend B you're
going on my favorite spots can speak you
can tomorrow the 11th Friday the 12th
Saturday the 13th so there we go did he
send stoked that's right you're at the
card then I got cause of the clubs oh
yeah July 19th and 20th I'm very excited
about some of the best clubs in the
woman that back in a long time besides
when I did that's right that's that but
I got a whole new set for you guys I'm
excited for him all new material one
Harper some new material see Sam frag go
see Brian and San Fran spoken since he
see you this weekend t fat K comport
tickets this is the fighter in the kid
we're out